hey guys it's justine how's it going so
you guys have been requesting to see
what is on my iphone and usually when i
get a new iphone i don't restore it i
just download all of the apps again so
it's basically a really fresh freaking
iphone so i'm gonna show you on my apps
i've got quicktime running which now in
yosemite and ios 8 you can screen record
super easy that's what's going on here
and i'll probably end up putting it
right here as well so you'll be able to
get a better look at what's going on and
you'll probably see some notifications
popping up so please disregard so when i
use my phone i do something a little bit
differently i always go in and i type
like okay i want instagram and i do it
really quickly and i just click on the
apps most of the apps that i use are on
my home screen but i also have things in
folders i never end up actually
scrolling to the second page because
they're all in folders and most of the
stuff if i want to find something i just
scroll down search it find it so my home
screen i've got the calendar app the
clock google maps swarm swarm is four
square
but it's swarm it's basically the old
foursquare just completely different
i don't know i've got the app store i've
got my settings i have instagram
hyperlapse and here's my little video
making line i've got youtube i got the
capture app studio youtube studio is
kind of cool it's for creators so that
it allows you guys to kind of go in edit
your video title your description tags
and stuff like that so it's super easy
most importantly my starbucks app
snapchat if you're not following me on
snapchat make sure you do it's ijustine
real easy same screen name as everything
else i've got my tweetbot app which is
one of my favorite twitter apps although
when i post photos i try to use the
native twitter app on the phone because
it usually posts them higher quality
which is
next one over inside my sports app i've
got my penguins my steelers in my nhl
app in my photography
folder we've got jiffboom
jiff
is how you say jif after light canon cw
which allows me to pull the images from
my canon cameras front back
photo i look i kind of like photo lump
hotel
oh perfect it's my best work also got
shots which i don't ever use
aviary which is a great photo editor i
got my gopro app i have tiny which is
kind of a cool app as well
of looping videos and
that's gross i'm deleting it i've got
dropbox evernote imovie camera plus
and that's all that's in my photography
i have an entire folder dedicated to
facebook because
facebook has a lot of apps
inside this little folder is another
little social folder got my four square
i have rooms which actually i'm gonna
have to move that to my facebook folder
because it's an app made by facebook um
i've got my audible app i've got oh this
is actually awesome so ripsy allows you
to add a gif keyboard so basically you
can be typing to someone and you can
send them an animated gif right like
magic so you hit this little world down
here that'll switch to if you have
emojis installed that switches to that
keyboard hit it again
and it'll bring up the riffsy keyboard
and it gives you all sorts of different
categories so you can click on the
hashtag and you just click it it copies
it and you paste it
there's an ijustine
chip collection
hello zed um this was really a great day
when i got to meet zed he was so
freaking nice blame it on the j j j j
jif oh my god my hair was so dark here
and if you hold down on it send it to
imessage email twitter facebook
messenger whatsapp hipchat i don't have
whatsapp or hipchat no
hey you come back this is my shopping
folder it's probably the most important
open table which you can use to make
reservations for restaurants amazon
my life dunkin donuts also my life eat
24 it allows you to order food from
restaurants and deliver it to your house
paypal my apple store uber
i was helping my sister look for an
apartment so i've got zillow and lovely
ebay at t
fancy app cartwheel that's uh that's
target's app lots of savings
uh the extras folder this is all the
standard apple stuff yeah nothing
special oh except a couple little extra
things uh sign now is what i use when
people need
things signed star rover is what i use
when i see a constellation i'm like is
that the big dipper
no
i stopped recording oh my gosh this is
quite the process all right next folder
is my home folder this is kind of for my
connected home i've got nest drop cam
and hue hue is pretty cool it allows me
to control the lights in my house
myfitnesspal allows you to track your
food intake so you can add what you have
for breakfast lunch and dinner and it
will calculate all of those things
together and let you know how many
calories you ate how many calories
you'll need to eat to reach your certain
weight goal pretty cool fitbit
moves moves is awesome but it's always
constantly running so it'll show you
exactly where you go throughout the
world nike training also another fun
little app for fitness this is my
entertainment folder i've got my xfinity
my netflix
and adobe shape doesn't belong in there
adobe shape allows you to take photos of
things and turn it into
a vector image so you take the picture
it draws the curves out recording
stopped again
why you gotta do this to me phone and
that my friend says what is on my iphone
so let me know what's on your iphone let
me know if there's any apps that you
guys think that i should download
because there's nothing that i love more
than a nice new fresh app that i should
be using on my phone i think i'm losing
my voice i've been playing a little too
much video games and yelling at my
screen there's so many good games coming
out in the next month i'm gonna lose my
mind i'm probably going to
be checking back in with you guys at
some point and you'll see me right here
rotting in this chair you guys enjoyed
this vid give it a thumbs up and i will
see you guys in my next one see ya